hey guys how are you so a lot of you
guys asked in my gold macbook unboxing
you guys wanted to know how it runs how
the 480p
they call it the eyesight camera now
whatever they're calling it these days
the quality is not that good so i
thought i would give you guys a little
quick peek of what it actually looks
like and i'm going to test out first
hand what final cut x looks like and
runs like on here and i'm going to show
you guys the usbc adapter because
basically i have not even been able to
use this thing i don't have anything
that's usbc
first of all the first day that i had it
i felt trapped i felt very trapped
because i wasn't able to do anything i
had no other usbc
devices so i couldn't actually hook
anything up to it this is our first
connection into the outside world until
other devices start using usbc it really
does upset me that this is not a magsafe
i know i've tripped on my cord several
times and the magsafe has saved my
laptop so i have a feeling that there
will be
many disasters occurring here now
without the magsafe charger don't mind
the pc in the background i'm sorry
cheating on my my mac products got this
guy here we're gonna try to make a
little video and we're going to show you
what that looks like if you're going to
facetime with somebody the quality would
be perfectly fine but i used to shoot a
lot of my videos back in the day on my
eyesight camera taking a picture
like it looks fine it doesn't look
terrible it's 480p
it's it's not 4k like what do you expect
okay here we're gonna make a video
really quick see what the audio sounds
like hi i'm just making a quick little
video here to test out the new macbook
pro
gold video and audio on the macbook so
this is it
this is what it looks like here you have
it stop the audio actually doesn't sound
too bad okay i'm i'm not i'm not like
really impressed but i'm not completely
disappointed so we're going to use the
adapter and i'm going to grab a piece of
footage off of an sd card i just want to
be able to have this
be good enough that if i'm like all
right i'm on the go
i need to edit
freaking usb man okay the disk i
inserted was not readable by this
computer
we're starting all over we're going to
plug in
the disk you inserted was not readable
by this computer so this is not good
clearly this is not good if you freaking
messed up
my sd card
pissed oh not readable okay great well
now i'm really really
unhappy let's see if i can just use my
camera to get the file off like you want
to get the files off the camera why you
gotta be so rude let's hope this works
okay let's import
some things are happening
okay not too bad not too shabby
guys it's actually not too bad
it's not too bad
hey guys so it's day two at coachella i
think we're probably just gonna hang out
at the house today and
okay let's see how the export is this is
this is exciting as long as i can do
some simple video editing everything is
gonna be
okay is it okay is it okay laptop looks
good
okay great that was only a 41 second
clip but i feel like it's going to be
good enough to edit simple things i do
have to be completely honest with you
guys because i planned on returning this
laptop i bought this one because it was
one of the only ones that i was able to
get the day one that it was available
and the one that i pre-ordered for
myself was the silver and i specked it
out to be a little bit higher so i got
the bigger hard drive i also added the
higher processor so it's a 1.3 instead
of 1.2 which you could add on at the end
whenever you go through the cart so i'm
not sure what i should do i think i
might do a giveaway of this one because
i was thinking that it wasn't actually
gonna be a good computer but i really
freaking like it so i think that's what
i'm gonna do i might do a giveaway i
haven't figured out how i'm gonna do it
yet but i did relaunch my new website
ijustine.com so on there i'll probably
put all of the details and you guys can
sign up so there's an all new sort of
like forum and ranking so you guys can
join in on all the fun so if you go to
my site you can click on sign up or log
in if you're already a member and yeah i
plan on doing a lot more with that this
year so i'm excited to see where that
all goes and i'm excited about this
computer especially if i want to do some
blogging because let me tell you what
you can do really well on this type i'll
see you guys later
i love you bye